I think that young people should listen
to their own hearts and they should seek
knowledge they should really look at go
beyond the the news that they get and
seek real knowledge and also search for
alternatives to to war and there are
lots of good alternatives they can look
start by looking into their own local
environment are they in school or in the
university where do they get their
information from our somebody trying to
manipulate their way of thinking are
there is some injustice in their local
environment that they would like to do
something about and then probably there
are in justices and there will probably
also be organizations or groups of
people that are addressing these issues
so they should inform themselves about
what is existing are there somebody
addressing their main concerns if there
is not anybody addressing these concerns
they might want to rally all the young
people with them we have had this
fantastic mobilization we are the 99 and
they are the the one percent we have had
the indignados or day and in year in in
France we had the beginning of the Arab
Spring which was exceptionally
encouraging so there are many ways that
can involve themselves but seeking
seeking knowledge as a support for their
own feeling that something is wrong so a
combination of believing in themselves
and seeking knowledge and then seeking
partners and many of the big
nongovernmental organizations have used
sections and are very very happy to get
more young people on board because we
have to admit that many in the peace
movement are getting a literally people
so combining experience and youthful
energy and you thinking I think it's a
good is a good thing